Be careful, huh?
Thank you.
Shoot him!
The world is at your feet
Michael,
do us proud!
You are going to become a doctor?
Yes, it's my passion.
Christopher Myers.
Chris is a star reporter for the "Associated Press".
A toast, to old friends and new!
Bravo!
Ana is a fine woman, Michael.
You make me feel like I'm home.
She is very fond of you, it's obvious.
It's very dangerous for our meetings right now.
I want to get you out of here.
If it's not safe for me, then it's not safe for any of my people.
What is this "Associated Press" thing here?
Reporting on the war.
There is no war here.
No one here is safe.
I have to get us out of here before there's no time left.
I was told that you're organising the escape route.
How can I help?
Ana!
Do you love him?
Michael! Run!
You trust no one.
Chris?
We will build a future together.